ça c'est ce que dit le nouvel
observateur il ya quelques mois il a
publié une enquête qui classe
l'agriculture parmi les métiers qui
rendent le plus heureux alors c'est
marrant parce qu'en france il ya un
suicides d'agriculteurs tous les deux
jours ça c'est un paradoxe est dans mon
métier c'est loin d'être le seul il ya
cent ans les agriculteurs on était
cinquante pour cent de la population
active un actif sur deux était
agriculteur aujourd'hui nous sommes 2 %
toute petite minorité
et malgré ça nous sommes le deuxième
employeur de france déjà sur nos fermes
chef d'exploitation + salariés on est
plus d'un million et chacun d'entre nous
moi comme vous me voyez je génère cinq
emplois en france
alors les emplois générés c'est en amont
de la filière ce qui va concerner la
recherche fabrication d'intrants
aliments pour le bétail vétérinaire
enseignement et puis ensuite il ya tous
les emplois qui sont en aval de la
filière transport commercialisation
distribution bref alors chef
d'exploitation nous sommes cinq cent
mille un petit peu moins et un sur trois
sont des femmes dans son des
agricultrices et puis un sur cinq
seulement à moins de 40 ans aujourd'hui
le renouvellement des générations en
agriculture il est moins facile qu'avant
pourquoi parce que c'est un métier en
quelques années qui a profondément
changé mes parents ils ont eu 30 ans fin
des années 70 début des années 80 mes
grands parents qui étaient agriculteurs
aussi ils ont eu 30 ans à la sortie de
la deuxième guerre mondiale et ce qu'on
leur demandait c'était simple
c'était de produire la france avait faim
c'est un pays en ruine à reconstruire
il fallait produire moi aujourd'hui j'ai
30 ans et ce qu'on me demande c'est plus
du tout la même chose
ce qu'on me demande ben voila je suis au
coeur de plein d'enjeux économiques
environnementaux et écologiques
sociétaux sociologique
ça va bien au-delà du simple enjeux
alimentaires
moi aujourd'hui ca c c'était pas comme
ça pour les générations d'avant je passe
une bonne moitié de mon temps à remplir
des papiers à faire de l'administratif
et puis à noter tout ce que je fais pour
bien être sûr que ça correspond à plein
de lois de normes dans la plupart n'ont
pas toujours dû être écrites par des
gens qui avaient beaucoup mis les pieds
dans les champs la pax et 4000 pages les
bonnes conditions encore
environnementales se sont dits cette
directive européenne transposée dans
notre droit sein c'est quand même hyper
complexe et tout ça je dois bien sûr
l'appliquer à la lettre
sinon je me fais sucré mais aides pac
les aides pac
nous y voilà les agriculteurs des
assistés
un cliché d'un cliché qui nous colle à
la peau et qui nous blesse aussi alors
juste pour info en france le budget de
l'agriculture c'est 2,9 milliards
d'euros on va rebondir 1,3 milliard
d'euros par an c'est le même niveau que
le budget des anciens combattants voilà
l'écologie c'est cette la défense c30
l'enseignement 46 font pressants voilà
alors l'impact qu'est ce que c'est la
pac depuis qu'elle existe depuis les
années 70 la pac c'est pour chaque
production dont on a besoin en europe un
prix plancher et un prix plafond donc
l'agriculteur il est rémunéré à un prix
juste pour cette production
alors allez expliquer à quelqu'un qui a
toujours travaillé comme ça que depuis
2007 un petit peu avant mes grosses
réformes en 2007
l'agriculture est rentré dans les
accords de libre échange de l'om c'est à
ce titre la révolution on n'a plus le
droit de subventionner directement les
productions par des aides directes
donc on a des aides qui sont indexés sur
des rendements historiques des surfaces
femmes en bref aujourd'hui au lieu
d'avoir une rémunération juste comme
avant il faut expliquer à tous les
agriculteurs qu'il faut qu'ils aillent
scruter le marché des commodities au
chicago board of trade à l'euronext de
londres et c'est qu'il a vendu 5 e moi
j'ai vendu mon blé récolte 2012 à 250
euros la tonne et 2013 180 entre
parenthèses on dit toujours c'est les
céréaliers qui font augmenter le prix de
la baguette de pain je ne sais pas si
vous avez vu la baguette de pain baisser
de 30 à 40% voire 2000
trèves un bon alors aujourd'hui mon prix
de revient c'est un peu comme à la
loterie
il va se décider en fonction des
positions des fonds d'investissement
dans tout incorporation des
biocarburants enfin des matières
premières agricoles dans les
biocarburants
il va dépendre d'une parité d'un prix du
pétrole voilà énormément de facteurs qui
vont influencer ce prix là c'est pas
évident pour anticiper pérenniser une
entreprise ont alors les aides pac si on
y revient ses 7,7 milliards d'euros pour
les agriculteurs français enveloppe
annuelle
ça représente un effort de 100 euros par
habitant et par an pour assurer notre
indépendance alimentaire
alors c'est une n2 certes qui fait au
secteur alors en france tout et aider
les individus sont aidés beaucoup de
secteurs sont aidés le tgv est et des
airbus est aider l'industrie automobile
au début de la crise elle a touché plus
de 6 milliards d'euros fin la
restauration l'agriculture elle est
aidée pourquoi parce que c'est un
secteur stratégique
bon je voulais dit nous sommes quand
même le deuxième employeur de france
entre les emplois directs et les emplois
que nous générons et puis on est quand
même leader mondial sur plusieurs
secteurs les vin les spiritueux leader
européen sur les semences sur les
céréales sur la viande bovine tous les
ans l'agriculture c'est plus de 60
milliards d'euros d'excédent sur la
balance commerciale on se tient à peu
près avec l'aéronautique
c'est beaucoup plus que
les cosmétiques et le luxe ou beaucoup
plus que l'industrie automobile c'est un
secteur stratégique toutes les régions
du monde est de l'agriculture si je
prends des cinq dernières années 2008
2013 aux états unis c'est + 40 % des
aides à l'agriculture brésil + 60 %
chine + 130 % et en europe d'un témoin
bizarrement on est les seuls on est les
seuls à baisser notre soutien à la
production
alors moi aujourd'hui je suis deux à
trois fois moins aidés comme agriculteur
nord-américain et même par rapport à mon
voisin allemand qui fait des céréales
puisque je fais des céréales et ben je
touche entre 80 et 100 euros de moins à
l'hectare pour aller poser sur des
marchés et puis être compétitif ce n'est
pas toujours facile
ça s'appelle une distorsion de
concurrence et des distorsions de
concurrence
c'est pas la seule que je subis y en a
d'autres par exemple sur les ogm alors
les ogm organismes génétiquement
modifiés
qu'est ce que c'est ça veut dire qu'on
va introduire dans le génome d'une
plante le gène d'une autre plante qui va
lui apporter une caractéristique par
exemple résistante à la cession à la
sécheresse résistant à un herbicide ou
capable de s'auto de nourrir soto
nourrir alors je m explique un
agriculteur il doit apporter des engrais
sur ces cultures pour le nourrir azote
phosphore potassium phosphore
il doit apporter sa à la plante au
moment clé où elle en a besoin pour
grandir
voilà elle a besoin de cette nourriture
et bien aujourd'hui le soja alors le
soja c'est une plante très particulière
elle a la capacité de fixer l'azoté de
l'air donc elle s'auto nourrit en fait
et il ya un gem intelligent qui a été
mise au point il ya quelques mois et qui
permet de prendre ce gène hla du soja et
de l'introduire dans les autres céréales
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire d'un que
demain l'agriculteur n'aura plus besoin
d'aller apporter des encres et danses et
chants d'aller pan train de faire des
interventions çà veut dire quoi moins de
coûts d'intrants moins de coups de
gasoil si ça c'est pas de l'écologie
alors les ogm c'est ce qui est
extrêmement drôle c'est que bon vous
savez nous on n'a pas le droit d'en
produire en france est absolument
interdit en revanche c'est autorisé à la
production chez nos voisins de l'union
européenne elle
en espagne pologne j'en passe donc
puisque nous sommes un marché unique
et bien tout le jambon pata negra c'est
vachement bon plein d'autres choses
qu'on mange qui viennent de nos pays
voisins et ben sont ogm premier ogm ça a
été commercialisé en 1995
ça fait 20 ans que nous mangeons tous
des jeux des ogm bon le monde entier un
produit états unis argentine brésil
afrique asie est alors le plus drôle de
tous c'est que nous importons en france
dans les ports français 4 millions de
tonnes de gm par an mais ça c'est pas
nouveau ça fait ça fait 10 15 ans donc
vous allez me dire m'attendais mais les
faucheurs
les faucheurs il faut jeter par celle
des ogm alors oui il faut effectivement
des ogm des parcelles ogm mais ce sont
des parcelles de la recherche publique
et de programmes souvent parrainées par
des instances comme l'inra outre alors
il faut charger m
ils savent très bien et s'ils le savent
passer c'est dramatique que pour
empêcher les ogm en france c'est pas de
faucher des parcelles de la recherche
publique qu'il faudrait faire mais
plutôt d'aller bloquer les ports alors
attention je ne dis pas que je suis pour
ou contre les ogm
je dis pas faut en produire faux pas en
produire ça c'est un débat de société
moi je dis qu'aujourd'hui en tant
qu'agricultrice je n'ai pas le droit de
produire des produits dont on me nom de
le marché et qui sont produits à moindre
coût puisque les ogm permettent de
baisser les coûts de production les des
coudes et des passages sur les sur les
cultures ce que je dis aujourd'hui c'est
que en france on n'arrive même pas à
dépassionner le débat cinq minutes et
que sous la pression de certaines
associations ou de groupe ou de lobby on
n'arrive pas à avoir une recherche
publique à long terme qui permettent de
prendre des positions scientifiques
claires alors qu'aujourd'hui aucune
étude sérieuse et validé dans la
communauté scientifique dans le monde
n'a pu prouver que les ogm étaient
dangereux jeudi que le monde avance
jeudi que les choses elle bouge que les
biotechnologies ça se développe partout
et que si nous on prend pas ce sujet-là
en main et bien demain nos enjeux
alimentaires et de santé publique seront
dépendants s'ils ne le sont déjà
de la recherche étrangères et privés je
dis qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'idéologie qui
prend le pas sur l'économique sur la
science et sur l'humain
l'idéologie je me rappelle cette phrase
d'einstein qui disait qu'il était plus
facile de changer un atome de place
qu'une opinion
je m'en rappelle à chaque fois qu'on me
dit et toi tu étais en bio non je suis
en conventionnel agriculture
conventionnelle raisonner avant le sont
pas bio des céréales non elles sont
avions alors la différence
je vais essayer de vous expliquer
concrètement ce que ce que c'est entre
les deux un agriculteur à partir du
moment où ils s'aiment et oui récolte il
ya deux choses qui doivent faire pour
intervenir sur ces cultures 2001 c'est
nourrir sa plante ça je voulais déjà
expliqué et 2 c'est la protéger la
soigner il ya trois types
d'interventions ou de sons pour protéger
ses cultures alors la première ce sont
les herbicides les herbicides on les
applique
va pour empêcher que d'autres espèces
concurrentes viennent envahir notre
culture et puis puiser à sa place les
ressources dont elle a besoin dans le
sol la deuxième ce sont les fongicides
ça c'est quand il ya des champignons des
bactéries qui viennent attaquer la
plante de l'intérieur prendre leurs
tiges la feuille tintin c'est un peu
comme un cancer ca détruit et le
troisième type de soin de protection ce
sont les insecticides
ça c'est quand on a des vols de
ravageurs de prédateurs qui peuvent
détruire un champ en deux trois jours il
vaut mieux intervenir
voilà alors quand on va dépendre des
traitements dans nos champs on n'y va
pas déjà pour le plaisir d'autant plus
que ça coûte de plus en plus c'est
excessivement cher le poste de coo enfin
intervention phytopharmaceutiques
phytosanitaires dans une exploitation
ils ont explosé donc c'est super cher
c'est pas ya trente ans où l'on traité
peut-être quelques fois en préventif un
assurantielle un peu à tour de bras
suivant les conseils de techniciens ou
autre ça aujourd'hui c'est fini
déjà il ya en dix ans on a la moitié des
matières actives homologué dans l'union
européenne qui a disparu il y avait 800
en 93 en 2003 n'avait plus que 400 mais
bizarrement finances parce qu'elles sont
interdites en france mais pas en espagne
c'est marrant ils ont beaucoup plus de
matière active homologués ils sont
interdits de chez nous mais bon
donc voilà on s'amuse pas à les étendre
pour le plaisir c'est un petit peu comme
quand on va chez les médecins
quelquefois ai dit non c'est viral faut
rien faire d'autres fois tu vas
prescrire des antalgiques des
antibiotiques une hospitalisation ça
dépend de la gravité de la maladie et on
apporte une réponse adaptée
alors les bio donc la différence c'est
que les bio aussi très depuis qu'ils ont
les mêmes problématiques quand il ya des
attaques de maladie ou votre bain faut
traiter mais eux ils ont des matières
actives homologué qui sont différentes
par exemple les bio l'agriculture bio on
traite beaucoup à base de soufre et de
cuivre le souffre et le cuivre sont des
matières actives donc homologué bio et
leurs particularités c'est qu'elles ont
une rémanence dans ce qu'on appelle la
rémanence et le nombre de temps que le
produit va agir sur la plante dans la
plante pour la protéger avant d'être
éliminé donc le cuivre et le soufre ou
des matières actives en bio en général
ils ont une rémanence beaucoup plus
courte que les produits homologués en
conventionnel
donc ils doivent aller traiter plus
souvent et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
face à des problématiques ou saturés le
sol de cuivre et de soufre ça rend tout
simplement tout simplement infertiles
saturé ça se retrouve aussi dans les
nappes phréatiques
c'est pour ça que les traitements bio
sont tout autant contrôlés et suivi que
les traitements conventionnels
d'ailleurs la traçabilité de nos
productions et tout ce qui va être le
suivi sanitaire c'est c'est très
important on est très très suivi sur ce
point c'est tout à fait normal
il ya un gros risque par exemple sur le
blé un gros risque qu'on a sanitaire ce
sont les mycotoxines les mycotoxines
c'est une maladie qui se développe avec
des conditions humidité plus de chaleur
c'est une sorte de champignons et des
mycotoxines s'agit génère des
mycotoxines qui sont des micro
organismes hyper dangereux pour la santé
humaine donc quand on en a dans nos blés
dans nos céréales ou cd classé en
fourrage et où c'est invendable ça c'est
un risque vraiment qu'on est obligé de
contrôler par des traitements et alors
je prends l'exemple du danemark
il ya entre 10 et 15 ans ils ont passé
toute leur production de blé en bio et
bon il était autosuffisant ils
produisaient pour eux
et puis il arrive à exporter aussi
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas su contrôler
ce risque de mycotoxines et donc ils
sont obligés d'importer tout le blé
qu'il consomme 1 2011 allemagne crise de
l'e.coli plus de quatre mille malades 1
800 dialysés avis plus de 50
germées bio 2012 série d'intoxications
alimentaires régions paca
languedoc-roussillon en raison de
résidus de datura qui est une plante
hyper toxiques pour l'homme qui était
resté dans de la farine de sarrasin bio
alors chaque fois qu'on a les scandales
alimentaires ce qui est marrant c'est
que des convois qui sont liées au bio
est disparue ils disparaissent assez
vite des unes des journaux
bon alors je suis pas en train de dire
encore une fois c'est pas le bio c'est
blanc ou noir conventionnelle c'est
blanc ou noir ce que je dis c'est que de
dire tout ce qui est bio c'est naturel
et donc c'est forcément bon pour la
santé alors que tout ce qui est chimique
c'est forcément mauvais pour la santé
c'est un mythe c'est un mythe il y à
quoi 60 ans mais toutes étaient bio y
avait pas de traitement chimique et
combien de nos arrière grands parents
mourraient à 60 65 ans voilà il faut
pouvoir
un petit peu nuancé tout ça et il ya des
agriculteurs qui font bien leur travail
des deux côtés le bio c'est plus facile
à faire sur des cycles courts cantonais
du maraîchage a passé beaucoup plus
facile de contrôler les maladies sur un
cycle de 20 à 25 jours
quand on a des grandes cultures avec des
cycles longs quand on traite dans c'est
pas simplement pour le plaisir de
traiter c'est parce qu'il ya une qualité
sanitaire qu'on doit préserver sur nos
parcelles
donc ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand on applique des
interventions sur les parcelles on le
fait en dernier recours moi je fais un
maximum de travail mécanique du sol sur
une parcelle avant d'intervenir de
manière chimiques et je suis la première
aussi à vouloir préserver la qualité de
mes sol et améliorer leur taux de
matière organique
les agriculteurs nous sommes les
premiers protecteurs de notre terre
notre terre à tous et les premiers
protecteurs de l'environnement donc
valoir aujourd'hui ben jeu
je suis fier de mon métier ce que je
fais j'aime beaucoup voir grandir mes
plantes les accompagner du semis jusqu'à
la maturité je fais un métier qui est
techniquement très pointu la plupart des
donneurs de leçons il imagine un monde
où il fait toujours beau où il ya
quelques gouttes de pluie quand il faut
mais pas trop mais il s'imagine pas que
dans deux ou trois jours je peux voir
une de mes parcelles où mes cultures
ravagées par une grêle ravagé par une
maladie ravagé par un vol de prédateurs
et qu'au bout de deux ou trois mauvaises
années je peux mettre la clé sous la
porte
moi aujourd'hui je suis donc en
conventionnel résonnait il ya deux
apiculteurs
ils viennent tous les ans posé plus 200
ruches à côté de mes parcelles de
tournesol et de colza et s'il revient
d'en poser tous les ans c'est parce que
la récolte est bonne et que les ruches
elles sont en bonne santé
j'ai un lac aussi que j'utilise pour
l'irrigation venez voir la biodiversité
qui a tout autour des oiseaux des ronds
des canards des grenouilles des serpents
des papillons enfin voilà il ya beaucoup
de choses à avoir donc oui je fais un
métier un beau métier que techniquement
pointu qui exige beaucoup de capacités
d'adaptation parce qu'en agriculture
quand on fait à on sait jamais si on va
avoir un résultat b y ou wef
c'est voilà donc je sais que je donne
aussi des des produits de qualité à
manger aux gens et j'en suis fier donc
oui j'ai de la chance